usually so private Alexandra pettifer or
Tiggy leg Burke as most of us know her
had wanted to be at the high court for
an apology she's been waiting over 25
years for the BBC finally admitting that
allegations she had relationship with
Prince Charles were wholly baseless and
should never have been made their lawyer
adding the BBC did not at the time
adequately investigate serious concerns
over the circumstances in which the BBC
secured the Panorama interview with
Diana Princess of Wales
this isn't just about how Martin
beshears secured the interview as Lord
Dyson pointed out in his report last
year it also is about the woefully
inadequate way that management looked
into allegations made against him as
early as 1995 and 1996 not just letting
down Princess Diana but also many others
in 1993 Tiggy started working as a nanny
for William and Harry but in 1995
Charles Spencer Diana's brother was told
by Martin Bashir that Tiggy was having
an affair with Prince Charles that she'd
been pregnant and had an abortion all
lies that it seems partly encouraged
Diana to do the Panorama interview and
also confront Tiggy about her suspicions
the following month
a statement read on her behalf said
sadly I am one of many people whose
lives have been scarred by the deceitful
way in which the BBC Panorama was made
still today so much about the making of
the program is yet to be adequately
explained
Matt fiesler was the graphic designer
who Bashir asked to produce fake bank
statements when he told management he
was ignored I don't think it's right for
people to go in front of a
House of Commons inquiry to sit in the
House of Lords when they themselves know
that whilst they were on watch something
went wrong and they think they don't
have to explain anything to anyone it's
that sort of arrogance that will make
never make it go away for me
Diana's brother tweeted he was pleased
for Tiggy but added he was amazed that
so far there haven't been any criminal
charges apologies and settlements not
enough to completely heal the sense of
deception and hurt Rihanna Mills Sky
News in central London